we mentioned offline daniel negrano um
i'm gonna get a chance to talk to him on
this podcast and he's somebody that i
was i found fascinating in terms of the
way he thinks about poker
verbalizes the way he thinks about poker
the way he plays poker
so
and he's still pretty damn good he's
been good for a long time so you
mentioned
that people are running these kind of
simulations and the game of poker has
changed do you think he is adapting in
this way
like the top pros
do they have to adopt this way or is
there is there still like
over years
you basically develop this gut feeling
about
like you you get to be like good the way
like alpha zero is good you look at the
board
and
somehow from the fog comes out the right
answer like this is likely what they
have this is likely the best way to move
and you don't really you can't really
put a finger on exactly why
but it just comes from your gut feeling
or no
yes and no
so gut feelings are definitely very
important um you know that we've got our
two mobile
you can distill it down to two modes of
decision making right you've got your
sort of logical linear
voice in your head system two as it's
often called and your system on your
your your gut intuition
um and
historically in poker
the very best players were playing
almost entirely by their gut
um you know often they'd do some kind of
inspired play and you'd ask them why
they do it and they wouldn't really be
able to explain it um and that's
not so much because their process was
unintelligible but it was more just
because no one unders no one had the
language with which to describe what
optimal strategies were because no one
really understood how poker worked this
was before
you know we had analysis software you
know no one was
writing you know if i guess some people
would write down their hands in a little
notebook but there was no way to
assimilate all this data and analyze it
but then you know with when computers
became cheaper and software started
emerging and then obviously online poker
where it would like automatically save
your hand histories um now all of a
sudden you kind of had this this body of
data that you could run analysis on
and so that's when people started to see
you know these mathematical solutions
and um
and so what that meant
is
the
the role of intuition essentially became
smaller
um
and it went more into as we talked
before about you know this game theory
optimal style but as
also as i said like game theory optimal
is about um
loss minimization and being
unexploitable but if you're playing
against people who aren't because no one
person no human being can play perfectly
game theory optimal in poker not even
the best ais they're still like they're
not you know they're 99.99 of the way
there or whatever but this it's kind of
like the speed of light you can't reach
it perfectly so there's still a role for
intuition yes so
when yeah when
you're playing this unexploitable style
but when your opponents start doing uh
something you know sub-optimal that you
want to exploit well now that's where
not only your like logical brain will
need to be thinking well okay i know i
have this my i'm in the sort of top end
of my range here with this with this
hand uh so that means i need to be
calling x percent of the time um and i
put them on this range etc uh but then
sometimes you'll have this gut feeling
that will tell you you know
you know what this time i know i know
mathematically i meant to call now you
know i've got i'm in the sort of top end
of my range and um these this is the
odds i'm getting so the math says i
should call but there's something in
your gut saying they've got it this time
they've got it like uh
they're beating you maybe your hand is
worse um so then the the real art this
is where the last remaining art in poker
the fuzziness uh is like do you listen
to your gut how do you quantify the
strength of it or can you even quantify
the strength of it um and i think that's
what daniel
has i mean i i can't speak for how much
he's studying with with with the
simulators and that kind of thing i
think he has like he must be to still be
keeping up um but he has an incredible
intuition
for just he's seen so many hands of
poker in the flesh he's seen so many
people the way they behave when the
chips are you know when the money's on
the line and you've got him staring you
down in the eye you know he's
intimidating he's got this like kind of
x factor vibe that he you know
gives out and he talks a lot which is an
interactive element which is he's
getting stuff from other people yes yeah
and just like the subtlety so he's like
he's probing constantly yeah he's
probing and he's getting this extra
layer of information that others can't
now that said though he's good online as
well you know i don't know how again
would he be beating the top
cash game players online probably not no
um
but when he's in in person and he's got
that additional layer of information he
he can not only extract it but he knows
what to do with it
still so well
you